ciao zio ben e tu bene bene bene
[Musica]
da allora ci vediamo il 24 sera non ho
mai fatti anch'io ho detto meno male che
non facciamo sia 24 25 perché un cenno
le pasta danza è poi bisogna smaltire
dai va bene ciao ciao ciao ciao
[Musica]
salve signora si tutto bene grazie
non ho il 24 sono con la mia famiglia mi
disp
però posso passare dopo cena si aspetta
aspetta aspettato un po tralicci ciao
alice ecco come stai bene bene tu sì ma
ci vediamo si si hai una sorella
ciao detto e eli scusami scusa mieli si
tutto beneficia un bacino ciao ciao
[Musica]
quindi natale un altro quindi natale
niente allucinante 1 sotto natale a
accenderà tv sono film di natale
puntualmente coppia che si innamorano
colpi di fulmine limone duri sotto il
rischio e basta un po di pace per noi
single amore che figura diamo stasera
allora io ho preparato una piccola lista
così capiamo quelli che dobbiamo ancora
vedere un principe per natale visto un
amore sotto l'albero visto 12 volte
natale visto l'amore a natale visto la
scream è visto matrimonio dire non
abbiamo visti i turchi e forse l'amore a
natale grazie zia ma non dovevi carica
no vabbè le scarpe che vuole ma te l'ha
detto mamma per forza prossimo adesso
tito il mio aspetta amore ecco il mio
regalo di natale per te
grazie
è vuoto sì perché dentro c'è tutto
l'amore che io provo per te come regalo
più bello che potessi fare è proprio lo
spirito della nave è piaciuto ma adesso
da mini un regalo grazie delle scarpe è
detto che a gennaio iri scriverti in
palestra io tutti i giorni della mia
vita mi guardo allo specchio mi aveva
grosse su cosa vuol dire dare prenotare
di scarpe né di basiglio perché voi
chiamate palestra e dimagrisca è
presente la canzone di mariah carey all
i want for christmas esatto quello che
voglio per natale sei sempre tu sei
sempre stato negli ultimi quattro anni
sei stato il mio regalo più bello la
luce dei miei occhi la cioccolata calda
di una notte fredda la crema al
mascarpone su una fetta di panettone
amore grazie ti amo tantissimo per me lo
stesso ti amo più del di ballin senza
non lo sai che l'adoro ai presenti la
canzone di mariah carey ora tutto quello
che voglio per natale un rinvio
sei proprio tu sì perché sono quattro
anni che io vado a dormire sognando t e
mi sveglio al mattino pensando sono
quattro e tu sei la mia classe
sono quattro anni che sono single perché
tu ti accorgerai mai di me prova vi
metterò sei neanche prendi esistenza ma
non importa
non importa perché io ti amo ti amerò
per sempre
[Musica]
amore mio cosa facciamo adesso ti scelgo
un bel vestitino per natale allora
vediamo preferisci l'elfo rivolgo la
torre che super cure o il biscotto di
pan di zenzero
oddio per carità ma queste questioni
maglioni da uomo cioè un conto sono gli
animali che super carina come cosa ma io
quelli che vanno in giro col maglione
natalizio e magari se ne mettono 1 20 41
25 diverso perché pensano di colpire ma
che tristezza ma ti pochezza amore corda
che cosa ho preso allora gli maglioncini
a tema natalizio questo qua lo puoi
mettere i 24 sera è questo che è un po
più così tratto per il 25 è così vede
cuginetti sono contente fatichi tocco
essere bastano
e poi questo questo qui è che omette
questo qui vediamo alla zia ore sarà uno
sarà piccolo lo diamo ad alice no troppo
grande lo metto io amore che ci siamo
coordinati lo prende il posto di bello e
poi è finita qui perché bocciato il
cappello di babbo natale ma io avevo
pensato se tu metti questo qui e arrivi
a casa dalle tue cuginette penseranno
che è che tu sia babbo natale per
bellissimo sei proprio innamorato
[Musica]
allora dal 23 al 7 vacanza non ne voglio
sapere di nessuno
unico appuntamento importante 24 sera
cena di natale e possiamo fare questo
sforzo
dal 25 però che sono libero a devo
iniziare tutte le sere che non so
riuscita a vedere durante l'anno quindi
25 inizio p.zza v che ho imparato bene
tutti quindi da guardare
27 inizio euforia che il fortissimo
quindi il 27 già la pro finita 27 inizio
gli u2 perché esce la seconda serie b
assolutamente da vedere in modo tale che
poi il 29
inizio a vedere rupaul allora amore con
calma perché non ci sto capendo più
niente ricapitolando 23 sera da zia
concetta 24 mattina andiamo a ritirare
ovviamente il panettone per poi portarlo
a 24 sera dai tuoi perché il 25 a pranzo
siamo dai miei e quindi noi no 24 dei
miei ma anche 25 come anche sempre
tradizione si fa 24 c'è una ristretta
dei parenti e poi 25 va allargata perché
allora quella allargata cambiando che
quella allargata non vengo in tema
comunque vieni e anche allargata perché
vengono apposta i parenti da
caltanissetta quando la calabria trieste
è l'appunto l'occasione per conoscere se
non l'hai vista però sento parlare di
terra che possono invece io devo stare
con i miei quadri di sempre se ogni
settimana si dà loro
[Musica]
ciao a tutti sera buon natale arriva
famiglia famiglia marina marina molto
piacere molto piacere marina marino
piacere
il tornado di sangue e non dar vita e
piacere ma c'eravamo già conosciute alla
cresima il cerchio
i cugini di caltanissetta resetta quelli
calabresi hanno preso però poi dei tre
nipotini alice maria e d'età elisabetta
e allora io mi sono permessa scusate di
portare questo vino è un vino delle mie
zone si frega perfetto allora favia
bocciamo buon natale non aveva messo la
tuta così posso mangiare il 4 vogliono
puoi fare esplodere stasera poi quelli
che la suo denaro e chi s'è visto s'è
visto
di udine si quelli di novara che posso
sedermi non mi sento molto bene ma dai
veniamo